[Music]
his name was showmaker because he wanted
to make a show there's now canyon trying
to keep them in his jungle showmaker
picking them off like fish in a barrel
joe maker if there is one play that he
can find to win a game he will get it
nine goes in finally gets one but show
maker gets an instant reply now the shy
gets blown up by show maker
i think you can compare play styles
between baker and show makeup she will
not go out quickly now
oh baby not the next faker show maker
popping off
show maker you gotta love him this guy
is incredible has the personality and he
is truly a superstar in league of
legends today
[Music]
hey everyone before we get into the
story of showmaker we want to let you
know that we've partnered up with the
wonderful folks over at predator gaming
to put together the ultimate holiday
gift guide to give you that desperation
you've been looking for
yes giftspiration is a real thing
as of now let's get into it since the
pandemic turned me into a large house
cat i've been trying to get back into
running but let me tell you it's not
easy seriously i i ache like everywhere
one of the things that makes it more
bearable though is a set of good
headphones that won't slip out of my
ears while i'm running that's why i want
to get my hands on the latest airpods
they've got clever things like spatial
audio and they're sweat resistant which
means they're much less likely to fall
out of my weirdly shaped ears next i'm
looking to upgrade my monitor it's a big
decision because let's be real there's
no point having a high-powered pc if
your screen just sucks that's why i've
got my eyes set on the predator 27-inch
monitor from the xb3 series seriously it
doesn't get better than this for me
we're talking 2560 by 1440 resolution
the refresh rate comes in at 165 hertz
and no space is wasted with this
edge-to-edge screen for me there's just
no point upgrading anything else in my
setup until i get this monitor it just
makes everything else look better
a bit like me
i'm kidding
not really so i've been playing acoustic
guitars now for about 10 years and
finally i'm looking to get my hands on
my first ever electric guitar
specifically one of yamaha's pacifica
guitars everything i read about them
says they're well made and have a really
great sound to them if i could get my
hands on one of these i would be very
happy my neighbors not so much well
there we go that's my holiday wish list
are you feeling gift spied yet thanks
again to our friends over at predator
gaming and don't forget to check out the
predator 27-inch monitor from the xb3
series available at your local best buy
and with that let's get back into the
story of show maker
[Music]
ever since the early days of starcraft
south korea has been an esports
powerhouse they had the talent the
discipline and the money to set them up
for success and it was apparent in
league of legends maybe more than any
other game with the region claiming
championships at worlds for five years
straight basically korea had solved the
game they knew where to go
they knew how to prepare
and you could have infinite awards
that's what it felt like
and so therefore they had all the
information that they could ever want
they understood exactly when to make
plays and from a tactical standpoint
knew exactly what decisions to make at a
lot of different times 2017 was a battle
between two south korean giants samsung
galaxy and sk telecom t1 that saw the
goat himself faker reduced to tears
after a devastating grand finals defeat
it was that very moment that inspired an
up-and-coming mid laner who we now know
as show maker to truly start taking the
game seriously
as an 18 year old rookie inspired by
league's greatest player showmaker
entered the pro scene as part of damon
gaming and was instantly a bit of a
standout due to his aggressive play
style showmaker was a katarina main and
just
played reckless crazy league of legends
his name was showmaker because he wanted
to make a show this is what's gonna
happen see you later battle comic says
well the rest of you are gonna go down a
double kill goes to show maker
does a lot of damage though to all the
champions barrel is getting in there he
is gonna go down in the end and
everybody dodges it but look at the
galio dammit's on the top side this is
what i'm talking about there's the proto
belt onto an urgot i thought that guy
was supposed to have help i guess not
showmaker's got an aoe veigar ultimate
with this queue it just goes and deletes
people wherever they stand 800 damage
for you and you and you while show maker
and damwan finally made it from
challengers into the lck in 2018 the
year had been less memorable for korean
league fans on the international stage
china had dominated that worlds and so
pressure was mounting for a korean
comeback in 2019 but the tried and
tested super teams aiming to reclaim
south korea's league glory weren't the
only ones to watch in terms of
individual talent you really can't go
too much further when it comes to
in-form solo queue players than dumb one
gaming and just like all the whispers
over the off season of how well they're
doing in scrims the question should be
less about are they going to be our next
champions and how will undoubted talent
leap off the page and really perform on
the professional level damon who were
quite unlike their compatriots drew a
lot of attention and it wasn't just show
maker who did things differently the
version of league of legends that was
the best here in korea was slow
methodical
and just steamroller destruction of your
opposition and that's
not really how it works even though
damon do look like a steamroller
sometimes it's a different way of
playing and they leverage control
earlier and it looks like they're
you know playing with more reckless
abandon but i think for us um it's
mainly just because we don't
um have much experience with that i have
to assume something's up it's
everybody's coming around the corner but
show maker is able to dance around it
but that metastorm able to come out and
huge aoe damage comes in from the entire
side of domwan and they clean up the rim
but it wasn't just damwan's explosive
plays that was making them fan favorites
they weren't like the typical methodical
stone-faced korean league of legends
teams of the past and no one reflected
that more than showmaker his mode game
is just
top notch the guy knows exactly when to
troll his opponents he is always ready
with a teemo thumbs up whenever he gets
a solo kill it's out of control
i know this is absolutely gonna be game
they have four members remaining and
that's gonna end t1's blue side streak
[Applause]
entering worlds 2019 dam 1 had a lot of
hype behind them and in the group stage
of his first ever appearance in the
competition showmaker proved why it was
warranted barrel may be overstepped as
the fight continues there's the solar
player coming in but the quickest gonna
follow as well the equalizer comes down
knocked back into the wall first blood
to rainbow but down one are not done
with the fight yet better on the front
line to fight the storm coming out
the dive in from nuclear that's two
quick kills for damn one gaming barrel
is around here comes the dive in top of
this one looking at the kill double up
out of the way but a nice fight comes
through good pick up there for canyon
nuclear on the chase finds first blood
showmaker in for number two and damn one
step right back in sombrero the hammer
knocks nugget backwards rookie holds
under the trigger for now gets the
shockwave only onto canyon but the shot
glass does not vomit ning goes in
finally gets one but show maker gets an
instant reply now the shy gets blown up
by show maker who is putting on a show
rookie has no manner and he holds on to
the flash triple for showmaker but
unfortunately for showmaker and damwan
after finishing ahead of the defending
world champions ig in groups their run
came to an end in the quarterfinals
against g2 esports it may not have been
the cleanest series but it certainly was
a g2 series
and as they move in and as they close
the game they will knock don juan gaming
out of the tournament and g2 will move
on to the semi-finals in the wake of
worlds damon finished a disappointing
fifth in the 2020 lck spring split
prompting them to replace nuclear with
ghost for the summer and his arrival
made a massive impact on the team's
performance at the same time showmaker's
playstyle was also evolving to resemble
fakers right down to the champions he
picked such as leblanc and syndra but
with his own hyper-aggressive flair
thrown into the mix is that showmaker if
there is one play that he can find to
win a game he will get it
right like if he needs to execute or if
he needs to like assassinate one
specific target
then he will find that play and while
showmaker's gameplay style drew obvious
comparisons between him and faker
it was far too early to put them in the
same conversation i think you can
compare playstyles between faker and
showmaker but you can't compare
careers
or
it's i don't think you're allowed to
compare anyone to faker i think it's
just unfair on the person you're
comparing them to still domestically
damwan were putting up amazing results
and showmaker in particular was truly
putting on a show this barrel gets taken
down the dragon's actually helping out a
showmaker gets rid of the trundle so
there are no smites for this particular
fight moonlight vigil goes absolutely
wide notary flashes forward triple kill
instantly i thought they nerfed the aoe
on the battle star in goes show maker
gets into his shroud is gonna get
executed and it's gonna be a carly that
locks down the dragon there's a perfect
execution i love
watching this guy's akali quadra kill
and trophy's like no i'm back to the mid
lane
who gets away
as well the tp's coming in hungary
trying to get this as showman coming in
from behind trying to make this a fight
and he is doing so much as karia can't
quite keep up and he's going to be able
to get that kill on najobi because of
the global pandemic the fast approaching
worlds 2020 was doubly important it
wasn't just damwan's opportunity to
avenge last year's loss but also the
first international league of legends
land that year expectations are high
naturally for damon i think the last
year they struggled against g2 in that
best of five but they've been very vocal
in many interviews about how they wanted
to get back to wars they want to be able
to prove themselves and they definitely
want to get revenge against g2 esports
specifically how can you not be excited
they have been incredibly dominant so
when the time came for damwan to give g2
a taste of their own medicine they
served it out with a ladle for showmaker
and for dam 1 gaming this is personable
this score is a translated quote but he
wants to crush you two into pieces as
soon as possible he said that he wanted
them to be gingy he said screw lck
guaranteed in the final give me that
rematch oh my show
solve
maker
words oh no that is bm dan one gaming
though set their sights on the nexus
down one gaming set their sights on the
final they look to g2 they take their
time with but they sweep aside the lec
and for the first time in three years
the lck will advance to the world final
the match-up ended with g2 taking the
fastest loss in world's history damwan's
revenge had been sweet they were the new
generation of korea's league talent and
they were about to prove that it was
their way or the highway this tower is
down and i think the showmaker shockwave
did not really do much one fight is
taken out in the backside of the fight
and sofm will respawn only to die and
watch his nexus explode dom 1 strike
first and finals minions are still
hammering away on the next start the
exhaust will slow down the inevitable
deaths but not the ace will not stop and
save the base dam one are one win away
from being crowned world champions dom
one will silence
shanghai and dom one gaming are your
season 2012
world champions after damwan won worlds
2020 it looked as if korea was back on
top but just a couple of weeks after the
team's defining victory nuggery who'd
been showmaker's partner in crime left
damwan for fpx it was definitely a big
shock uh when nuggery left dan juan
because everyone had been talking about
how him and showmaker were just like
this power couple you know they just
kind of clicked that team just seemed to
work and when he left for fbx everyone
was wondering okay is that it then for
showmaker is he done is he going to be
like half his normal power now without
his partner in nugary but doubters and
naysayers aside showmaker's star still
blazed so bright not even kpop idols
could resist
[Music]
early 2021 put the question of whether
showmaker could go on without nuggery to
rest and the answer was a resounding
definitive yes that had question marks
around khan he's had a great tournament
this time as well seems to have fit in
to uh nuggery's shoes quite effectively
there's now don juan they're gonna take
down the nexus pretty slowly i think
they'll look for a couple more kills as
joe maker yeah some hold position as he
looks to try and take down rich he goes
into his zonias for a little bit but uh
unfortunately showmaker unable to get
above that 8.6 that we gave him earlier
on but still a very good yoni
performance and congratulations
to don juan gaming now kesper cup 2020
slash 21 champion the uh the nexus is
now showmaker is going to go golden
that's a big pulverize but it's not onto
the victor life's going to get burned
down by the death ray ruler in a bit of
trouble canyon is going to stun him up
and show maker takes the kill canyon was
down to like what what else all right
well congratulations for your series mvp
canyon the nexus falls down and don juan
kia get the 3-0 over genji and will be
your spring lck champions a hiccup at
msi aside damon looked poised to become
two-time world champions especially
after their smashing performance during
the lck summer split where showmaker
came face to face with his idol in the
grand finals so it's hunky
we're three minutes into the game and
faker might just die to the turret
although show maker's just gonna laugh
at him
throws up the thumbs up and that's it
for faker over here it's gonna be able
to take him down and look at this
renekton he can't get the kills under
the turret the jinx lives and diego
still around
pushes hitting the base as well during
this oh man they're just running through
the turn and they will blow up owner
it's like a freight train right now
they're taking down everything in their
path looks like this is gonna be it guys
game number four is going to go the way
of tom one they just have to hit the
nexus and dom what kia will be your
champions of lck summer 2021 in a
devastating three to one victory as
exciting as it was for showmaker to beat
his hero on route to claiming his third
lck title there was still work to be
done if he was ever going to catch up to
faker and build his own legacy and a
second worlds win would be a crucial
part of that puzzle even though damon
looked a bit different this time around
the team's world's winning formula
wasn't solely reliant on the showmaker
and nuggery combo canyon was still
around and the way he and showmaker
synergized in game was a sight to behold
showmaker i think is the best
facilitatory mid laner
in the world and the way that he works
with canyon is so beautiful hills oh and
the real morphin
man he just can't catch a break this is
rise and trundle how about camille how
about all three of them get in there and
bully he's just gonna burn down to the
ignitus khan he doesn't have to look at
the explosion he know he got the kill
you can't really talk about showmaker
without talking about canyon because
either of them alone would not be as
good as they are combined dk absolutely
demolished every opponent on their way
to the grand finals of worlds 2021 not
losing a single game until their best of
five against t1 which they still ended
up winning three to two they're gonna tp
top as well they have the elder dragon
they have a wave they have everything
they need to go to the world finals and
damn old legends and old legacies
goodbye faker goodbye t1 hello dom juan
and show maker they will defend their
title in the finals and look to go back
to back
for every question t-one posed dom one
had an answer game five was incredible
from them never allowing theo felios the
azir to take effect never allowing them
to find that fight t1 forced into a
no-win situation where they have to hard
engage but they don't have the tools to
do it the new era of the lck has well
and truly arrived as it is don juan
standing above the rest
damon and edg first seeds of their
respective regions were set to face each
other in the grand finals
damon had a nearly flawless run and were
the defending champions so they entered
his favorites but edg didn't get the
memo edward gaming absolutely wiping the
floor with our former world champions
they make sure they finish the job
before they finish off the nexus first
blood had been drawn by the chinese team
but damon responded emphatically
there's the ultimate kiana goes right
into the wall and that is indeed a
supreme display of talent showmaker
going golden but can he actually stay
alive after the fact that supreme
display of talent says absolutely yes
it's don juan kia they will route edg
that's a clean ace and they will win
game two all of the teleports to come
forward as now khan is walking the wrong
way but maybe it's the correct one as
they pick up the kill on the twisted
fate they knew the men advantage was
coming in and he puts himself in the
right position to capitalize can't make
the big play khan into the backside
though he'll be able to do it locks down
scout before he can do anything and
ghost grabs the kill onto jj and this is
the team fight that darwin kia have been
looking for all game long laundry goes
down as well and mako he's running for
the hills but he's not going to be out
of stock but the nexus is exposed and
darwin kia will move to match point in
this series unfortunately for
showmaker's team edg were determined to
go all the way and wrestled the final
two games out of damwan's grasp your
2021 league of legends world champions
edward gaming i don't think it was about
don monkey necessarily being figured out
it was more about them being tested for
the first time and edg being tested for
the third time
and they were pretty good at the exam by
then you know afterwards a few of the
players contracts including show makers
were up for renewal and for a short
while there it looked as if all of damon
swayed by the force of their defeat
might go their separate ways after their
second place finish at both msi and
worlds this year three of the five
players who played in those tournaments
ended up leaving the team but showmaker
and canyon returned to try and make
history once more whether the roster
shuffles do the trick is of course yet
to be determined for now showmaker's
quest to overtake the goat remains a
work in progress a work he could
complete by showing us more of the sort
of player that he is
one of the smartest sometimes also the
most selfless mid laners that we have in
the lck and a player that's so capable
of analyzing a situation
and making the smartest call whilst also
having extraordinarily fast hands one
thing's for certain though showmaker has
become a generational mid lane talent
and he's not slowing down but in order
to be mentioned in the same breath as
true greatness there's still a mountain
for him to climb fake just kept doing it
year after year and i think for show
maker he still has a long career ahead
of him and we won't really be able to
tell i think if he won this world then
we could start having a conversation but
he didn't so
we're gonna have to postpone that for at
the very least another year we haven't
seen that i think in a long time since
you know faker made his way up and that
was in a different time right like being
able to make that transition from solo
queue guard to professional league of
legends mid laner that can consistently
find advantages and victories that is so
hard to do because they're like solo q
and and and pro play are very very
different beasts but the way that show
maker so beautifully managed to
transition
into the player that he is today
is something that needs to be spoken
about
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tick tock
[Music]